for years we have loved playing dungeons
and dragons because of its unique and
collaborative storytelling experience
together we have brought to life
characters and moments that will last us
a lifetime so for son of a dungeon we
want to bring that life to you
too for our game table we have partnered
with dwarven forge to bring you some of
the coolest miniature terrain you'll
ever see and we've gone a step further
by digitizing it allowing us to put
ourselves into this fantasy world and
give you a perspective of d that you've
never seen before
[Music]
now i was just about to play the first
episode but there's something really
really important i have to tell you this
show has been 12 months in the making
and was made entirely possible with our
corridordigital.com
subscribers you see we have a green
light feature on our site that allows
our subscribers to vote and choose which
projects their subscription dollars
actually go to because of that we made
crew cuts which is our studio vlog we
just reached our 100th episode of that
we also have functional filmmaking which
is our master class mini series that
details everything we do here after a
decade of filmmaking on youtube it's
really sweet and if you like this first
episode hop over to the website episode
2 is live right now and trust me this
show gets better and better and better i
love it it's so cool we put so much work
into it and we'd really love if you
checked it out on corridordigital.com
enjoy
cecilton
the name of the village you call home
cecilton known for its agriculture its
trade and most importantly the
decades-long and vicious sports feud it
holds with the city of wantinghamshire
more affluent neighbors
regardless of whether you're past or
present sports fans or connected to the
world of sports at all the occupation
that you
our players
share
is that of exterminator exterminators of
demons exterminators of aberrations
exterminators of creatures that are
unnatural to this world hopefully you're
good at your job too because you're
about to meet one of your greatest
challenges you've been summoned for an
emergency meeting in the woods outside
cecilton where marcella cecilton's
chancellor of sport has summoned you she
claims the pay will be high too high to
refuse
because she knows of something very
dangerous lurking in the abandoned
caverns beneath the village something so
dangerous it could put an end to
seaselton
and sports
as we know it
and so you have arrived
the sun is setting
and your story
is about to begin
welcome to the first episode of son of a
dungeon we've been really excited in
putting the show together and we're
finally here today to do it we have a
huge table we have ren we have d we have
niko we have jake it's a great party
really excited some of these guys have
played d d with before ren i'm i've
played d before but i'm a newcomer when
it comes to playing with you guys so i'm
excited to play yeah i'm super excited
once i uncover this stuff you guys are
going to get blown away don't worry
you'll you'll be happy with how things
go so
marcella
the chancellor of sport old marcelo has
given you an emergency call saying there
is a task
most peculiar
well gentlemen here we are marcella
yes yes
thank you for calling this meeting
i have heard from
not only my family but also from others
in town that there is a very serious
problem well we all know that the big
game is tomorrow evening correct and
well we have a bit of a an issue
happening inside here we all know
gorgeous greg of course he's uh the star
player of one shires sports team and
we all
look down upon him of course every time
we see him play we always want our home
team to win correct uh yes so uh he's
here he's here yes now this is a mission
where it requires an incredible amount
of discretion because as we know it's
not it's not
looked uh upon with the best light to
fraternize with players of the rival
team before a big game this is peculiar
indeed who are the nobles inside uh
before we get to the nobles i see some
new faces uh that you some people that
you have brought to this mission of
course i know you the bard the bard
everyone you know everyone in town your
name is passed around frequently and
yeah uh warren watt i am a half wood elf
half human i am a bard i carry with me a
guitar a mandolin and a smaller guitar i
also have a long sword a dagger i've got
a few other trinkets disguise kit some
other costumes rations things of that
nature got a few cant trips a few spells
that might come in handy while we're in
there i also have a crystal bead and an
eagles feather beautiful we have a very
good relationship but we have some new
people here and as before we bring them
inside
could you please vet them for me
[Music]
okay what a comforting way to introduce
strangers
[Music]
who are these friends of yours again
all right to my left we've got ness my
name is nest i'm a druid wood elf very
wise fella decently dexterous you know
i've been around season for years from a
little druid tribe that's been doing
various druid craft for them over the
years as they've run into issues with
nature in the city clashing together my
focus is on tactical magic you know
aimed at nature so handling animals
things like that we'll uh we'll go from
there
okay
good and uh who is this big fellow you
know bob bob introduce yourself god damn
it my name is bob with a w and i grew up
in the woods i was actually adopted by a
family of chipmunks when i was a child
there was a storm a bunch of chipmunks
got washed out from their their home i
rescued them and we cuddled together
through the storm because
i just think this is hilarious that the
first time you meet someone you're
telling them all of this about yourself
and it wasn't very apparent to me at
such a young age that i was a goliath
and huge my this this guy little here
his name is chippy he is my best friend
in the whole world other than him over
there i trust him it's kind of funny if
you're super huge and you don't know
what normal size is like
that's that's funny like you just walk
around like man everyone's really small
everyone is really small
i'm a barbarian i like to crush things
or run sometimes i just have an
overwhelming desire to jump as high as i
can how high can you jump one time don't
do that don't ask him to do that but
secretly i've been putting money aside
for the family of chipmunks can i roll a
perception check to see if i heard
somebody take a sigh out in the leaves
[Laughter]
i sigh really loudly
a sigh echoes from behind the leaves i
step out from behind these trees
mysterious stranger steps out from
behind the trees who are you
who are you
mysterious hatted man
i step around the corner i go good lord
what do we have here and i walk towards
the group marcella
instantly sees this and she's like is
this one of your party as well though
marcelo i'm surprised you don't
recognize me i know it's been a long
time i've never i i would know you if i
knew you i take my hat off
i'm still i'm still a little unsure who
this person is
i go it's been a long time it's been
almost 15 years since i've been back to
the town
i used to live here when i was a child
hmm
oh that's
did you play sport as a child here not
as much as my father i've only been the
chance to live sport for five years so
that's that she's only been the
chancellor of support for five years yes
no
i'm still looking and i wouldn't know 15
years ago quite quite some time okay
then i wouldn't before my time yes yes
yes sorry uh but you seem
uh are you i thought you said i know her
oh
then i have to really do that because i
want to know who she is
wait
let's just let me take it back
is he famous
[Laughter]
well it seems like you see a witch
hunter step out mysteriously from the
woods and he seems to be here with some
sense of purpose i take a history check
14. okay my character is corvus conrad
he is a human witch hunter all black
witch hunter garb silver rapier and duel
can crossbows he is a dark and gloomy
kind of brooding person as much most
witch hunters are which hunters are
feared throughout the land because they
dabble in blood magic solitary people as
i told you i used to live in this town
when i was a child and it's been a long
time since i've been back conrad
your father put my hat back on
conrad unfortunately yes but that's also
partially why i'm here
go on witch hunter i was visiting
mcallister's home for wayward boys where
i used to grow up and even from that
distance i felt a dark presence from
this cave so i was waiting till daybreak
because it is quite dangerous to enter
and uh i heard all of you making this
big commotion so i'm wondering are you
planning on entering this cave going in
as a party or having backup is generally
a good idea so i'm very interested in
what this contract is that you have with
this woman
which hunter we have a great contract
with this woman we've been working with
marcella for quite a while now
of course we could use someone who knows
blood magic to help us get through this
cave
um especially someone such as yourself
who can sense these sort of dark things
um i'm sure we can figure out the
details of this but i am willing to
compensate you fairly i promise look
corvus i'm down to have you get my back
i need to know that you got what it
takes i wanna do a little test take this
log here and throw it in the air as hard
as i can you can shoot that with your
crossbow and hit that log square in the
center i know your guy has the skills to
back up his slick looks okay if that's
what we're doing oh can i throw it you
sure can
bob throw this log in the air yes let's
see how high it goes
i take the log and i rest it on my
fingers and i explode my hand out so
quickly all right roll strength check
okay real quick on that so strength
check i'll roll my d20 but what do i add
to it see your strengths see the plus
yeah the five okay
it's 10. you throw it up and it goes 20
feet up into the air uh i will shoot my
crossbow so
plus six
uh it's 11. yeah it's a stick yeah
i barely hit it
barely
how bad it would be if i missed that
oh boy
well so before we enter let me explain a
little bit of the situation here
within these caverns is
a club house sometimes the towns elite
like to go and spend time uh with each
other which is also part of the
discretion we don't want the location of
this clubhouse revealed your discretion
for what you see here and who you see
here
must be kept a secret there was a
special tea a delicacy gorgeous grade
brought to share with us we all imbibed
it and he began falling ill after
drinking it now i'm concerned for him he
is not the only one who drank this tea
tonight but he's the only one who has
fallen ill witch hunter why don't you
take the lead
here this this way it's completely safe
probably shall we fancy are we going
we're going we're going okay the sun's
almost set at this point and you walk up
to a small hole that forms a cave in the
rocks here it seems to go down
underground you see warm light coming
from inside the caverns it seems like
these caves are not as wild as you might
think they are
marcellus steps down into the caverns
here and i believe you follow the cavern
is filled with dim
torchlight your character's right you
see a
rickety old door that is unlocked and a
small sign that says do not go this way
danger and the reason it says that
is because on the other side of that
door two spiders massive spiders that
are just staring at you silently ahead
of you you see a small statue
with a interesting little symbol on
there symbol you might not immediately
recognize
and then to your left there's another
open pathway marcella begins to walk
this way this way this way she says
let's go that way all right i'll follow
her as we pass i asked him do you
recognize that altar you see that it's a
altar to the god
uh cyric which is known for trickery
a chaos god god of trickery you walk up
to
two incredibly thick
doors they're gilded that are uh sealed
in front of you and marcella walks up to
the front doors and begins knocking wait
wait wait wait wait wait marcela where
are you taking us
i'm taking you to
the clubhouse where greg is he's inside
how many people are in here marcella
there are some people here some you may
recognize
but as i said
who is in here other than greg
i'm i'm probably going to recognize some
of these people so i'm going to put on a
disguise
he said i started putting on makeup turn
around like a mustache
yeah i have i have was an entire
disguise kit and two costumes
yes and as i said discretion is
incredibly important you are not
knocking loud enough does anyone else
want you i i walk forward and i start
banging on that door whoa whoa whoa whoa
bob i go keep your
goodness great
are you following through on that i i'm
gonna follow through and uh i i
i go to knock on the door i go to
persuade bob to not do that hey bob what
are you doing don't do that that's a bad
idea i got costumes you need to put one
on because that could be bad if we go
inside everyone recognizes you you're
huge and seven feet tall if you go in
there everyone will know
maybe you could stand out here and send
in chippy
instead
that would be much better do you stop on
your own accord or not i've been
persuaded i okay
i just i wanted to my guy is like my
guy's [ __ ] sweating right now he's
like these [ __ ] people are gonna get
me killed
i'm gonna do an insight on her because
she's being real shady she's being real
shady
we did insight on her and she said the
fact that she won't tell us like what
we're supposed to do with him or how
many people are in here
i feel like she's she's definitely
hiding something i'm gonna do an inside
check on her and like read her body
language like see like if she's sweating
or anything
that's 20.
she's 21. she's scared there are things
inside of here that
the music is not helping
the music
please
that's this is incredibly annoying
please this is not the time for your
strumming now if you're going to go in
there like a nervous wreck this is going
to go horribly you gotta calm the hell
down okay that's my main point calm down
okay i will calm down okay i'm going to
knock we need to go inside immediately
okay
she wraps on the door hello
i'm back i'm back let me in let me in
let me in a voice on the other side of
the door it's like marcelo you're
banished you can never come back inside
no you have to let me in you don't know
what you're doing fancily has been
stealing open the door bob sillies
that's
you're going to get yourself killed open
the door bob
full strength jack
24 oh
slams the door
you see dust just shoot up from the
walls in the ceiling and uh like
some
dust comes down
but the doors do not
break damn and on the other side you you
hear
what the hell was that
marcella did you bring more people here
no i didn't i i had to i had to you're
gonna get yourself killed i say you hear
that yes
and we won't come through it
with what just did that
gentlemen
dealt with doors before
marcel is there another entrance in yes
there is another
okay there's another take us to the
other entrance we're not getting through
this door where does those spiders where
does that route go i do know those are
just wild caverns i do not
go in there there's a sign that
explicitly says it's dangerous gentlemen
spiders are the chipmunks of the insect
world they're not something to be feared
that hallway like it's trivial you see
the size of those spiders yeah they're
like big dogs yeah look it's not a big
deal
i can i can go in there we can walk
through it they won't be a problem i've
dealt with spiders before
if you guys could just give me a moment
see if i can deal with this in a
non-violent way get us through there
without any issues good call cool with
that
i'm cool with that i'm completely cool
with this we must get inside no matter
what happens okay let's go
lead the way as a recap the sign says do
not enter danger how locked is that door
how locked is that door it looks like
there's no lock on it a wooden door made
out of like five inch thick wooden logs
with a rope and a knot not the best
construction it's not designed to keep
people moving in and out more just like
unintelligent creatures gotcha all right
so guys i have on my chest i have a
bandolier of uh various vials of potions
herbs funguses uh in one of these vials
i have a fungus that's very attractive
to insects so i'm gonna go up to the
door first i'm gonna give it a sense of
these animals these spiders i'm gonna
try to do my animal handling to see if i
can keep them non-agro and eventually
get them off into the corner you know
and unafraid of us and we can quietly
slip by i'll show you all you guys how
to move spiders don't get angry at you
all that good stuff basically they're
friendly creatures as long as you're not
a bug no big deal they're mostly
scavengers okay
do we i'd like to see let's see what you
got druid it's very important to me that
we don't kill animals who have done
nothing wrong to us that's kind of
murder so yeah okay
okay just let me shoot you guys it's how
i feel man let's see what you got drew i
want to see this it's up to me to save
these spiders lives yeah because if you
don't kill these spiders marcel
instantly says i'm gonna step back
this is a little frightening all right
sam i'm going to attempt to handle these
animals
uh 16. okay well the spiders uh
instantly like
leap forwards and like okay so i'm gonna
put a picture of it off in the corner
right here you gotta flick it through
the door yep
and then
go go go quietly smoothly perfect you
flick a little bit over there and they
instantly crawl off to the side and now
they're sideways on the wall
like over there using their little
pinchers to like try and taste this
stuff all right now guys we're gonna get
back here without incident we got about
a minute uh don't make a lot of noise
move quietly okay all right great open
door open the door
here
i draw both my crossbows and i'm ready
to shop with both of them
uh i get i'm the last one through i put
marcella in front of me and i kind of
walked you were walking and you look
down and you see a corpse covered in
spider webs bones flesh rotting looks
like they've been dead probably monks at
this rate but they're in the corner
shriveled up marcela
what is this someone's died in here oh
i don't i don't think i can continue
pretty standard adventuring stuff a dead
corpse rotting
yeah yeah yeah
there's a door in front of us uh
yeah you're on it
okay i opened the door
[Music]
oh look at all these contraptions in
this room what's the light situation
going on in this place this is a dark
ass
room pitch
black except for a warm orange glowing
light coming
from the left side of the room you see
very little you can see some logs up
ahead some that it's a little strange
but you see some logs and you see warm
glow over fire in front of you see a
small
fungus sprouting up from the ground
well i'm gonna light a torch and toss
into the door
so you throw it light a torch and you
huck it into the middle of the room
it lands
glowing and illuminating the room now
twice as much with two fires burning in
the room
and you hear a drone you hear
what's that
oh
[Applause]
there's a people coming in here
old raspy voice
hey
yeah someone threw a torch in here oh
that's crazy
people haven't been down here and then
he's just your muffled shattering
continuing okay i walk into the room and
i pie the corner with my crossbows he
thinks he thinks we're gonna get him
killed he's gonna get us
see three figures around the campfire
but it's hard to see who they are do
they notice me
no
they keep they you just hear muffle
talking and you hear the sound of what
seems to be like paper shuffling these
are already stealthing up uh so warren
and nest are at the doorway
and d is rolling a stealth check
correct yeah i'm gonna just kind of like
creep closer towards the shadows up on
the altar stealth check that's a 12.
stealth check 12. i love it they don't
hear you
i'm gonna creep up a couple steps and
i'll let them do what they're gonna do
so you start walking up and you become
quickly in range of both being able to
see them
and hear them a lot more clearly okay
they're frail
bony you see bones you see ragged
clothes they
look like
workers or something like that they they
[Music]
they are not
currently alive by your standards all
right they are undead
and they are sitting there like oh well
if it was nothing
i suppose it's your turn and you see
them passing a card to the other person
i've got charm
um
i can charm up five characters within 60
feet of me
they can we have them for an hour if i
if i am able to defeat them and then we
could have them move in front of us and
tell us maybe these guys don't seem like
a problem that's what i'm saying i could
use a level one spell on them we could
also just probably force them to do
whatever we want even if we charm them
then they'll
then they'll they won't like okay how
about this how about this you do that
trick them into i'm gonna stealth in the
back yeah and ready to attack on them in
case it fails sure so look over at
warren i point both crossbows at each
two of their heads and i look over you
and i signal you to like get their
attention
tell you what real quick i'm going to
also take out my boat and i'm going to
ready an attack
no i i i just kind of
saunter up to them i just talked to him
you're still wearing a disguise what
does this guys look like again it's the
it's like i'm i'm an elf servant elf
servant yeah pretty cool
so i just walk up to him and i'm like
who's winning today all three of them go
oh hey you're right it's a fleshy one me
is he a
hey get me some give me some water
which way to the clubhouse
you found it
you want to play game
yeah deal me in
all right here we go
they deal they take all their cards and
they'd give you two cards okay
work the game's crazy you guys can
pretty much do whatever you want right
now you're freezing when
okay great all right all right wait
let's make a bet first if i have a
higher card you got to tell me something
about you
if you have a higher card i'll tell you
something about me
all right
three two one go roll uh d6
six
five oh it's regular so high oh no
well something about me oh
how'd you get down here well we used to
be miners down in that hole what were
you making underneath the bridge
oh we're high of mine and some crystals
until we got eaten alive who what'd you
get eaten alive by oh it's a worm really
is it still in the cave just 50 years
ago probably not
but they pooped out our bones for
somewhere we came back to life
did someone reanimate you i guess they
must have
well that's crazy to think about
there's a bridge that goes over a
massive
hole
it goes straight down
i think mike's balls are still down
there
too bad for him uh currently you just
see that there's a drop-off ahead of you
all right i'm gonna go up here i'm gonna
check this thing out what's this well
you see uh what looks like something
that used to be a rope pulley
uh there's no rope attached to it uh i
look up at the old dudes
i go
so you haven't left this room in 50
years
i think about 50 years the only way we
keep track of time is how many card
games we can play so you guys are from
cecilton oh yeah i'm from
cecilton i went home i used to live
down main street
ah man
you know what'd be real cool is if you
could bring mike back to life so he
could play cards with him again or even
just bring up his bones and then we'll
play a cool card game so just be like
normal i'll give you a secret item if
you go down there
what's the secret item well secret
well back in the day when it was
lunchtime
with this big old horn that would blow
when it was lunchtime
you could hear
you could hear that horn all the way
through the deepest parts of the cavern
only promise
it's down there
we'll give you ownership of it if you
can retrieve it just make sure you bring
back mike's bones when you come back up
i'll make you a better deal
you come with us
we'll bring back mike's bones we'll get
the horn
and i'll get you guys a new deck of
cards oh hell yeah i'll go you come with
us
yeah i'll come down all three of you and
the other two look at each other's we
should probably stand here
how are we gonna go down like
our fingers will break off don't worry
about that you'll be fine all right
let's get it
so you guys are gonna
go down that cavalry i'm gonna send them
down
and see what happens
because i only can see 60 feet which
isn't enough to tell me anything because
it's 100 feet i don't do i don't do a
campaign without this horn anymore
i've learned better than to not include
it
so it's definitely worth getting okay
let's do it whatever whatever you guys
want to do uh let's take let's throw the
torch down the hole
good idea and so you light it and you
kick it over and you see the flaming
torch go
and it
crashes to the bottom of this 100 foot
pit and an explosion of embers and
shatters boom there's a whole new area
and you see illuminated
bones of mike
and you see a bunch of these crystals in
the bottom of this cave
this cavern
this
uh pit
and then well the old guys will come up
and they lean over the edge
oh here he is
there's all mike's bones
how much rope do we have
i have 60 feet i got another 60 feet i
could just climb down don't do that
i'm very dexter if you fall in this game
it's massive damage you get d6 damage
for 10 feet so this is 1086 damage you
probably could actually
you probably could just straight up just
jump off the edge and probably survive
but you'd
be hurt you really feel like this horn
these guys are talking about is worth
going down in that cavern and facing
whatever that worm they're talking about
is i heard about one of these horns one
time from what i understand about them
they have the power
to destroy a cavern
of this size completely
so if you blow the horn you go def
there's a one in five chance that you go
permanently definitely use it but it is
like an instant room destroyer oh yeah
and then on house rules are if you do
blow it in a very tiny area you still
could go permanently deaf because it's a
you know it's like shooting a
50 cal in a bathroom without ear
protection yeah
who's got the most dexterity i got a lot
of dicks i have a lot of athleticism you
should have uh you should have a rope
connect to you being held by bob
well we have this we have this thing
right here which is made for holding
ropes you and your brain
[Laughter]
i'm gonna take my rope i'm gonna start
tying it to this thing and i'm gonna
throw the other end down to corvus like
of course can you tie her up to mine uh
yeah i'll tie it to that and it'll make
it 120 feet
uh i don't have dark vision and i don't
really want to go down there so i'll let
you go ahead and do it i can't see
anything down there
let's get down there let's go find that
horn let's go
and you begin to climb down the road
okay
so give me like a basic an athletics
check for strength
17 16. you see
this old guy in the back
motioning to this guy up here he's
pointing up at the rope and the other
guy's scrolling
what
i'm gonna pull my crossbows out and
point out both of them and be like what
the hell is so funny i'm gonna
intimidate them
uh
13 plus 1 14. all right one of them just
did a roll this guy
you can't see him any longer in the time
it took you to look back and forth
between them
he's gone okay this guy is intimidating
he's like
what are you doing what are you doing
i'm not doing anything wrong i'm sorry i
repeat what the hell is going on oh you
know
we thought it'd be funny
to make you guys
fall down here i shoot him in the head
rolls initiative yeah you're in the
middle of climbing her up nico go for it
ren's above you
you're you're like 15 15 feet down and
you're basically 10 feet down okay oh
[ __ ] freaking bob
all right lots of water guess i'm using
spider climb
all right i hear this commotion and like
mmm this isn't gonna work so i cast
spider climb on myself until the spell
ends one willing creature myself gains
the ability to move up down and across
vertical surfaces and upside down along
ceilings while leaving my hands free so
that's my action i'd like to make sure
ren doesn't fall to his death can i just
like get in position to try to do deal
with that a little bit as my second
action you can move into what you think
would be a position to help him and
that's it
so what is that position
besides slightly above him and like with
a hand on his leg so you're about to
grab him yeah he's just about to grab
him okay yeah cool so you hear that and
up above you here
here we go
this guy who's right next to him so he
takes out the knife and goes like
and he takes the knife and he tries to
hit the rope for damage and oh he crits
the rope
little way old mikey got some french
slice the rope and wren immediately
lurches and you begin
falling you're in free fall
i'm gonna give him a shot at maybe like
reaching out and grabbing but we'll get
there okay
so oh it's your turn it is your turn
you're 10 feet down from
and nico is there
trying about to grab you with his arm
extended what do you do i
you got to think about this one well i
really wanted to get to the bottom of
this cavern
this is your ticket this is my ticket
don't take the damage
i reach out and i try to grab for nico's
hand all right this is the deck save 15
is something that's hard 20 is something
that's incredibly hard and 25 is
generally like impossible okay all right
i'm saying honestly it's a 15 deck save
to grab niko all right roll it all right
[Laughter]
nest reaches out of 10. bob
lung is for nico totally whiffs it and
you plumb it all the way
down you plummet 90 feet
lands on the spoon
and you take
28 points of damage
okay crunch you land on the bottom of
the cavern
with a definite
thud what is your hp what's your 60 you
have a 60 hp okay you're not bloody
that's impressive wow that's a pretty
massive that's almost half damp that's
almost half your debt you're almost half
dead
so to scratch you land completely prone
your next turn is skipped
because you're
lying there you need to still get back
up before you move or do stuff your turn
okay i shoot them both in the head with
a crossbow twice sounds good
which ones which ones this one and this
one
okay so this one's for the guy up here
top man
uh a crit on one hit and then the other
one is a 13. get hit let's just do
damage for that first
15 on this guy okay two arrows fly into
his skull and chest dude and he's
knocked back you would consider him
extremely bloodied if he had blood but
he's like just barely standing
like barely next guy nice guy
[Music]
13 and a
24. one hits four
seven damage tom
one arrow hits them right in the back of
the head not expecting it
oh they're fighting us oh [ __ ]
maybe we shouldn't have done that oh i'm
gonna take
two steps back
and because i have crossbow expert i
don't invoke attack of opportunity
that's sweet
this guy
sees jake right there standing on the
edge and he's gonna jump and try and
land on you to push you over so he jumps
you're rolling decks against the
strength check right strength roll to
knock you down into the pit
jeez this is a good dice dude i got a
20. better hope i can catch you
yeah cause if i fall that far i'm uh
gonna be knocked out pretty hard this
i'm rolling crits so you're gonna have
to roll 20. let me see what i get here
plus
seven 23.
but he not critted
that's a guaranteed win i'm sorry i i a
dm mistake was made um i've scribbled
your name between d and him because
technically you rolled a seven this guy
did a six for initiative so so i would
have it you still have initiatives you
glimpsed death
but you you you had a psychic intuition
of what was about to happen you look up
and see this guy he's poised to jump on
you
wow
i'm sorry i can't believe i'm turning
this around that was gonna be intense
uh okay well in that case you can
probably move
now you well that's not happening i'm
probably going to move
make it quick so i disengage behind d
you you disengage and like sneak through
here yeah exactly his reaction yeah and
you you go back there and that's your
holder all right boom all right so now
it's his turn and he's up here he he
jumps down here and breaks his knees and
falls prone the next guy goes the lead
one here turns around and sees d
shooting at him and he runs up to where
nico is and he takes his little dagger
and sees you there spider climbing and
he just throws his dagger down at you to
try and hit you with it okay he uh rolls
like an 11. yeah he misses the little
knife goes
flies down to the cavern the guy who's
stealth out of the way is up here now he
sees all this [ __ ] happening and he's
like and he starts running he's like
guys it didn't work
one two three four five six they're slow
and that's it and now it's back to niga
okay i am 15 feet down the hole 50 feet
gets me to here i still have 20 more
feet to move so i can like five 10
15 on the wall 20. yeah so i'll continue
in his way all right walking his path
and he runs
we really messed this up here's me we
got to make this right totally freaks
him out
you're down there
it's your turn you're like oh you can
you can get up
shake it off
but that's really all you can do in this
turn i get up i shake it off and i look
over and i see some bones on the ground
oh you look over you see the bones and
you see the horn
into his skeletal grasp clutching it oh
man shiny
horn in wren's hands
just gonna have it yeah you'll get it in
the next turn all right
and so it's corvus's turn yeah i just
run up to him i shoot him twice in the
back with a cross one shoot the other
guys twice with the crosstalk he's
rolling so first guys on the ground um
first shot because he's on the ground i
have advantage that's 16 second shot 23.
he hit hit this is the damage on the guy
on the ground 15. another 15 to him all
right you roll up him
two bolts go inside of his bones explode
and the body just tumbles
all the way down into the pit falls down
hits one of the crystals bones explode
everywhere it's just
it's just an explosion of bone shards
okay second guy
shooting him
uh
both 23
damage
16 damage oh wow so that actually kills
him too he's 16 plus seven you gave him
originally is another kill so
he turns around to see the bolts hitting
him one goes in his head the other one
goes in his mouth his skull explodes his
body just like crumples
flies down falls down into the pit
brandon looks up a second body comes
down
smashes against the ground bones explode
everywhere just rags and dust and it's
horrible
and i look down and go grab my bolt
[Laughter]
jake mr warren's turn let's see i should
probably focus on helping bob
get out of this situation that he's in
um i move up to the to the edge i call
down to bob
hey we got to get you out of there grab
that horn in those bolts
can you climb back up or do you need
rope and i mean some rope would be nice
well the rope is the rope is down there
right because you cut it i i take the
rope
and i coil it up into a small mass
and i attempt to throw it all the way up
100 feet
strength check never going to work
nat 20 plus five holy [ __ ] he [ __ ]
take it
and right away on your next turn you
take it you wrap it up and you just huck
it and the rub just goes
and perfectly comes off goes a hundred
feet
and lands on there and you just
relax
all right 100 feet is five times from
that like pipe right there insane i mean
if he wasn't a goliath i would say i'm
down dad 20 and he's a goliath that
makes sense
so almost everyone here is dead this guy
backs off he disengages from nest he's
like
this is really a mistake man
way i promise i won't mess with you guys
anymore you that you can still take the
horn
anything you want and he just keeps
backing backwards more and more all
right it's my turn yeah so my quiver of
ever growing arrows
snap one off and it's about time i flex
this long bow a little bit and
are you gonna kill him just right into
his face if i can help it if i can name
it i feel like we could get some
information out of him or something i'm
gonna kill him it's just how i feel okay
he tried to kill me he almost killed
nico yeah you guys did
put yourselves in a really precarious
situation
still if had they not tried to murder us
it wouldn't have been precarious
so
14 as a hit
all right what kind of damage does that
bow do uh six damage it doesn't one day
six damage two arrow goes right through
i mean it man we gotta get your friend
out of that all before the worm comes
all right it's your turn so you took the
rope and you throw it all the way up
all right the rope comes up to the top
and as you're looking up
from throwing that rope like you see a
rock wall going up and you see a little
thing jutting out and as you look up you
see a little hole of light shining
through this is imagine this is like
like a balcony of sorts where it's
imagine a cavern face and then there's a
piece jutting out underneath that piece
you see a little hole of light
okay
a hole of light a hole of light opens up
and liquid
it's not hard to identify that's urine
it's like a cool
wet
droplet are cavern
below like a latrine and just as the
urine continues to stop one tiny little
piece of poop comes
falling down and goes falls 100 feet and
splats
on the cavern floor next to you bob get
that horn and get the f out of that pit
i grabbed the horn i grabbed the bolts
four of them yeah put them in my pocket
so all right wren you hear a rumbling
underneath the ground grab the rope i
retie it to this thing you get the rope
on there the rumbling grows even further
rope dangles down you've gotten the horn
did you grab anything else i grabbed the
horn and the bolts and dude yeah the
body's sitting there and of course i've
got to search the body you find the
body's got 10 gold pieces on it you
found the horn already cool and you also
found a potion of greater health so dude
chippy check this out we got some money
the rumble grows further i grab
everything i pocket the the potion i
pocket the coins chippy and i giggle
over that i grab the horn and the bolts
get it all in my body and i grabbed the
rope with both hands you roll strength
check to climb up that rope remember
it's a 13-14
nat 20. hell yeah you freaking
you just
and right
and right as you get clearance
and you start going up right as you
start going up it this thing just bursts
out of the ground
and it bites at your feet but you are
going so fast that it can't do anything
this thing is straight up explodes and
starts slithering
around down there and it's still and
it's just now it's just sitting there
like waiting and kind of like slithering
in and out between the rocks and trying
to burrow and trying to do his thing you
successfully get up to the top yeah
please tell me i actually i fly up over
the edge and land isn't that twenty this
is like somehow three you go up but
still through three point land
yeah and stinky todd up here at the edge
of the bridge oh man that was a really
close one i just made it out of there
alive i really am
all right this time i mean
no more tricks i promise run up and run
up and kick them in the nuts
24 to kick him into the nuts kick him in
the nuts we're only some damage d4
uh three
five damage you kick him in the nuts and
his like leg pops off and he like tuples
over with like you know he's got one
bony legs
i run up with my long sword and i just
wait wait wait wait wait wait yeah
there's some reason i didn't kill him i
only kicked him in the nuts
you guys didn't want to kill him
let's toss him into the worm pit okay
good idea
[Laughter]
pops off he falls over and everyone
proceeds like you go up there you drag
him you over over the bridge and he's
like
[Laughter]
it and straight up just
boom the jaws just like destroy him
bone dust explosion
he's gone and then i take my card
the two cards that i still have from the
game and i go
and i throw them down and they they
slowly fall down the cavern ace is high
and marcela is sitting right there
mouth just jaw dropped it was a
brilliant display of adventuring she
comes up to he was like
are you okay you fell 90 feet
how did you survive well the poop
softened my fall
the poop softened
and she she goes to inspect the uh
balcony looking area that juts out and
she says oh
that's where the
latrine exits out i've never seen the
outside before
it's been filling up this pit this whole
time
it seems like
perhaps we could go in through this and
we could
circumvent trying to find where the
secret exit is
you guys want to climb through the poop
hole that's sketchy i mean i'm down
marcella i hope these ticket sales are
worth it because this is this is getting
ridiculous i still got my spider my
spider climbing on so i'm just going to
lock up the wall and go check out this
little hole you've got like just a few
moments left of spider climb you walk up
the cavern the side of the cavern to
check out the door and you see that it
is not fast and shut it's roughly a foot
and a half by a foot and a half wide
it's just barely enough to squeeze
through you see there's no latches no
locks it just seems like a wooden plate
how dirty is it
it's a little dirty it's a little bit
slippery but
it seems like uh it's not like a door or
it's locked no one expected for things
to come up from it
guys before bob's ready anything happens
he lost 50 points
i'm at 32 out of 60 right now i did find
a giant potion of healing let's heal him
in somewhere before we go yeah
okay two two three three
plus four ten fourteen hell yeah brother
all right uh i grabbed my rope i'm gonna
record a staff i should open because i
don't want to get any goop on me not
that bad just think i covered it it
ain't that bad
you take this quarter staff don't touch
your [ __ ] it's full of germs
and it just starts opening oh clicks
against the wall so you pop that open
and you poke your head up inside yeah
stealthily stealthily roll me a stealth
check
10
10
you
come up
no one's there
no one's there all right i'll climb into
the room is there anything i can fasten
my rope onto there is a stool with a
hole in it so here's what i'll do i'm
gonna take the chair i put it across
like one of the corners of that square
hole so it's kind of like resting
diagonally on it kind of rope to it put
the rope down great works you tie the
rope you put the chair perfectly on the
corner it's relatively secure relatively
it's a little slippery key key thing
guys the chair is relatively secure i'll
try to keep the hand on it marcelo says
who should go first this looks dangerous
i'm gonna start climbing
i'll take the other end of the rope and
i'll come back up here i'll tie it to
this again before i go i'll go so when
we get into the hole i'm gonna take one
of my crossbow bolts and we're gonna pin
it underneath the rope underneath here
so it's an escape route we can get out
good idea man corvus where have you been
all my life this is hunting
okay i start climbing athletics here we
go
uh that's an
eight uh
you grab onto the rope and so you're
gonna try and like shimmy across it your
hand slips give me a deck save just see
if you can reach the rope this is simple
this is a 10. uh
that's five
five yeah so both your hands flip from
the rope
and your legs are dangling
correct
okay you you're upside down hanging give
me an athletics check to get back on the
cliff can i give them some bardock
inspiration yeah that's a 1d6 to add to
whatever you're able okay so my my hand
slip my legs are there and he starts
playing a song
just do it give me strength check on to
that rope you got it hold on to that
you got it hold on to that rope
that's
that's my favorite song
you channel your inner strength you flex
your abs
you get the rope and you're just
boom boom boom boom all the way up and
up through the hole i think about that
one time i really effed it up when i was
a kid and i'm like i'm not gonna let
that happen again we're establishing we
are shimming means that means we're
getting you get two checks when because
your your hands and feet have to slip
okay then i go next okay
oh god okay that's
six
so you go you go and your hands slip and
you dangle from your legs and your legs
slide upside down back to the cliff
facing you someone probably could assist
him hell is
down slides down
this rope smells like [ __ ] you can give
it another shot okay here we go again
all right
climb it
it's even worse it's a seven
you go on your hands slip ah you're
still dangling by your feet i'm gonna
help them back i assist you i'm helping
roll warren
get quit screwing around and get off the
tank rope
i'm so glad i tied that rope off it's a
10. it's a 10 yeah you're back on the
collectors
okay
i'm going again no no no we're done
we're done you're the gambler here i'm
going he's just climbing plus 411
11.
you just barely barely make it across
that's so sad just to get on eleven all
right i reach i reach down and i help
you out dude i i'm surprised
one of your guitars didn't fall off yeah
i helped you into the hole marcelo says
well i suppose that leaves just us
that didn't go very well i i i'm not
sure
i'm still much confident it's okay i
have this hold on to me i'm holding on
to you all right i'm gonna shimmy across
this rope she's holding on she's not
letting go
it's a 20 d12
that's a d
gun you roll the d12 and said 20.
20.
oh
let's see what you got
fifteen plus eight yeah you're fine yeah
totally up there
she's holding on she climbs through
sounds good so everyone's inside this
little bathroom here
you see that on a casual inspection you
can see that it's basically stone but
wooden floors have been added little box
here full of like some soaps and towels
and then there's a little water basin
and mirror in there but it's a pretty
empty bathroom can someone do a
perception check to see what's outside
the door
um that is a
23. so you go up to the door to listen
to what's on the other side and hear
footsteps
[Music]
you hear a man and a woman talking oh
wait wait one sec one second one second
i'll be right back i promise one second
i promise i'll be right back right back
okay okay okay don't don't wait for me
just go go okay i'll be right back
there's somebody gonna come somebody's
gonna come through the door right now
we're gonna act like we were just in
here having a raucous party of you know
things that aren't supposed to happen in
a public bathroom all right okay hey oh
oh
hey i'm sorry is the door locked
immediate real persuasion on him or
deception sorry i hide
i guess i stand in a corner i dip back
in this corner so when he walks he
doesn't see us all the door opens a man
stands there then you look eye to eye
and i roll 22 on deception and i say to
him you know you really got to be
careful around here because the people
you run into in this club i gotta say
it's just some of the best people in the
world uh were you here to use the
bathroom i'm sorry
and the man stands before you you look
at him he's nelf he's wearing yellow he
has a guitar on his back he looks at you
and says oh oh i'm sorry i'm so sorry i
was i'm here here's the restroom and uh
i s you play music too oh i haven't i've
seen you here before we should seriously
catch up but one moment i must relieve
myself go ready okay he turns around the
corner and sees everyone bunched up
there watch out for my friends oh
he looks over everyone and like
i told you the party's in here
hey
[Applause]
he looks at everyone covered in feces
yeah everyone's fine marcella is
standing there and his back's turned to
you and he's like marcella
what are you doing here you are not
supposed to come back oh well
you're with us now i cast charm 18 natty
yeah you it works okay you and i
are now in a band together
[Music]
if you want to continue watching head
over to corridordigital.com
right now episode 2 is live and ready to
go with new episodes weekly we really
hope you liked it enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
you